so now we are getting a little bit more
good stuff when it comes
to our political order right now
there was there was a big win I hope it
will be a big win that happened
yesterday Elon Musk
officially became the chief twit and he
he did so by uh walking into Twitter
headquarters and he was actually
carrying a sink
it's a kind of a strange video
obviously being filmed he's just
carrying a sink obviously disconnected
from the wall and he smiles at the
camera and puts it down on the couch and
he said he tweeted out he goes entering
Twitter HQ let that sink in
sorry yeah and then he says it changed
his bio to say Chief twit
so this gives me a lot of Hope
because he's the man is certainly not
self-serious he makes jokes he thinks
takes things lightly that's what
Chesterton said about the angels He said
the angels can fly because they can take
themselves lightly
and he he says he's going to make
Twitter a little bit Freer he's not
gonna he's not saying it's going to be
the complete Wild West and you can put
whatever you want on Twitter but he's
saying we're gonna open up speech again
on Twitter it's got to be an important
uh tool for communication and this is
this has the potential to be a more
important political development than
pretty much anything we've seen during
the Biden Administration
and the reason for that is the Bird app
is not just a
worthless time suck that we're all going
to have to answer for when we make it to
St Peter's gate it might also be that
but Twitter
and Sir along with the senior Partners
in big Tech Google and Facebook are the
Public Square and because we are at
least in principle a self-governing
republic that means that they are the
political order if you can be excluded
from the Public Square then you cannot
really participate in our government
so your place in our self-government
doesn't really exist and if that happens
to an entire political party
if that happens to the biggest voices in
a political party then that means that
half the country is essentially being
booted from the Public Square and it
completely undermines self-government
this uh could be a big development now
Elon Musk is not
I don't think he's some rock ribbed
conservative
and it actually tells you a lot I think
about a lot of the poll movements we're
seeing today
Elon Musk just kind of gets what time it
is Elon Musk like so many Americans is
not a guy who probably showed up to the
Tea Party rallies 10 years ago and the
and wore the Maga hat all the time and
you know studied Edmund Burke in school
maybe he did maybe he didn't I don't
think so though I don't think he was a
debate Club kid wearing a bow tie you
know practicing his orations on
classical conservative philosophy I
think he's a kind of quirky interesting
guy who works in a completely unrelated
field to the professional exercise of
politics and he just looked around and
he said whatever ruling classes running
the country right now they're screwing
it up something's going really really
wrong and I'm not part of that I'm part
I'm just I'm out of that I'm with
whatever is not that you've seen Tulsi
gabbard do this you've seen huge swads
of Hispanic voters in particular do this
you're seeing a huge group of Center
people and Center left and undecided to
do this right now breaking in the polls
now will our benevolent Bettors you know
will our will our ruling class
uh be able to hold on to their grasp of
power despite this popular movement that
remains to be seen But the signs are all
very very good looking toward election
day representative Myra Flores
uh she's a Texas Republican member of
Congress she just tried to join the
Congressional Hispanic caucus
this is the main caucus for Latino
members of Congress and Myra Flores very
clearly Latino she's the first
mexican-born woman to serve in Congress
she represents a district right along
the U.S Mexico border the district is
overwhelmingly Hispanic
she was not allowed into the caucus
according to the Congressional Hispanic
caucus representative Myra Flores from
Mexico is not Hispanic
kind of silly right
why is that
well I don't they don't want to let her
in because she's conservative and as far
as the left is concerned if you're
Hispanic and conservative you're just
not Hispanic as far as the left is
concerned if you're if you're Candace
Owens if you're black and conservative
you're just not black
they don't say Candace Owens you you're
not conservative they say you're not
black you're not really a black person I
remember an article about Sarah Palin in
some stupid feminist studies you know
gender studies Journal this would have
been years ago when Palin was running
for vice president
and the article said that Sarah Palin
had surrendered her Womanhood she ceased
to be a woman because of her political
point of view
and we can mark this and we say this is
so silly and look at these dumb liberals
with their race politics but
this there's actually a lot to this this
is actually how most people think about
race very very few people care about
race itself this is across the political
Spectrum
people care about race if they care
about race at all only as a
representation of something else
so people on the right have very low
racial Consciousness you see this
reflected in a lot of polls of white
people especially at very very low
racial Consciousness compared to other
racial groups
in as much even the race obsessed kind
of Fringe of the right
even they
are more than happy to welcome black
right-wingers into their tent
even you see this and just look at any
of the real racially obsessed kind of
Fringe figures on the right
they've all got a black friend they've
all got a Jewish friend they've all they
they
because their their racial politics is
not really about race they just for them
the people who are not members of their
race that they pal around with
participate in the kind of cultural
trappings that they themselves go along
with so wear the same clothes believe
the same kind of political points if you
read the same books go to the same
parties do the same sorts of things for
the
the relatively few people on the right
who Focus all that much on race race is
really just a representation of culture
and for the left race is just a
representation of ideology
this is why they can with a straight
face say no my reform is you're not
Hispanic
no no because I know you think that race
is just the color of your skin and your
bone structure and but it's not for for
the left if you do not adhere to a
handful of dogmatic ideological
principles that make you a leftist then
you actually just can't be black that
when Joe Biden says if you're not going
to vote for me if you don't know who
you're going to vote for me or Trump you
ain't black he is expressing that point
of view he probably couldn't articulate
it in anything resembling a systematic
way but he's just saying that race
actually is not about the pigment of
your skin it's just that is just a
representation for your political
ideology and a lot of the time that does
actually match up and sometimes it
doesn't and when it doesn't then you
deny the pigment you deny what we have
traditionally understood to be race and
you you instead favor the symbol and
that that's why Myra will never be
Hispanic according to these people
never will Candace zones will never be
black according to these people now
today today was supposed to be a very
special day where I almost killed my
friend and colleague Jake crane we are
pushing that to tomorrow we're switching
tomorrow which is fake headline Friday
to today because listen we live in
Biden's America Up Is Down and left is
right and black is white and so
everything's crazy you've got to stay
tuned I need your help to figure out
which the fake headline is because the
news cycle is so so crazy four real
headlines one fake one
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]